okay let's move on and let's play
someone else wow so many people
challenging I'll play a sub if you're a
sub your name should appear purple if
your name is not purple and you're a sub
you should use a sub challenge command
and it will give you further
instructions how to make your name
purple so I'll play alley 33 the first
sub to challenge me good luck maybe I'll
keep playing again that's why not
we played once before and it was a draw
okay time to get revenge ooh I playing
gambit here I could invent again but
that's d5 a move feels like it should be
a move it's probably due yes but okay oh
I could have taken then played d5 but
that would be probably just a bad
Halloween because I I would need my
knight here if I'm White's I'll turn
player Halloween gambits subway 109
bonus 10 do you still have an echo
apparently not I think the echo only
happens when I'm streaming from my Mac
because my Mac is a bit weird mr. waffle
truck thanks for subbing woah
what are these Knights doing let's take
up on all four Center squares are
occupied on move 5 that doesn't happen
so often this nights hanging Bishop c4
is illogical trying to internalize
what's going on I could play Bishop here
and then it'll be more of a party I also
play bishop here let's play Bishop e6
just to kind of diffuse attack against
f7 also attacking the Knights the
bishops defended though by this fight so
this light can move somewhere
probably f4 III Eric needs to do extreme
on Halloween and just play the Halloween
gambit
I was just thinking about that I mean
the thing about Halloween is you can't
you can't play it against everything
only in like four nights positions
okay d3 looks questionable but why I
mean okay this nights hanging but this
nights hanging so usually the rule is
you you just like kamikaze the piece
that's hanging and then take the free
piece later so that takes off - hmm
anything better
oh let's take off - it's very strange
opening so far okay I'll take this thing
over today thanks so much for a thousand
bits and congratulations and being for
being in a good mood hope it lasts and
we have new subs we have Malorie
underscore exe and just Bondo's a really
appreciate that Kover and the new subs
and Zef cats
it's F cat reading with a party of 84
thanks so much tough cat shout out to
Zef cat and shout out as FCAT viewers i
really want to take a free nights but
then I get punished
you take the rook good bow test gambit
is it too early for a bow test gambit
probably well do a bow ties queen trade
whatever that means and then I wanted to
Castle queenside it won't let me though
I should defend the pawn
but rookie ones coming hmm okay let's
start with this oath FCAT says do it
well too late now sorry to let you down
I'll play King d7 it's a weird square
kind of for the king but it frees a eh
square and gets closer to connecting my
rooks there's a couple dozen gambits
just within the Kings gambit
yeah there's Carly again that's within
every opening few days ago I played the
[ __ ] your counter gambit against the
Kings gambit it's fun to play counter
gambits Zoff cat re subbing gifted by
Kevin Siwan thanks Kevin
and thanks F cats again for being who
you are
let's develop more pieces should d6
looks decent III so white wants to do
this and then eventually win the pawn
let's restrict white this was very
common in chess when they want to play
before you you crush their hopes and
dreams so it's equal material even
though I tried playing a gambit and it's
actually quite positional I have upon
gaining space but this is also a
potential weakness I mean yeah this is
kind of expected
I could play f5 just try and harass the
rook try and shoo the rook away from
attacking my pawn there we go
and now maybe rook e8 sand will trail
off everything
not sure whether trading one pair of
rooks or both pairs of rooks is
preferable let's trade off one pair
because the battery was scary and okay
positions like this okay position like
this I have to move quicker but
sometimes the first question to ask is
what what does the opponent want to do
I'm not seeing anything like so
immediate for white so I think I'll just
make some improvement play a four let's
play a four especially with the presence
of the dark squared Bishop s' I think
it's important for at least to try and
fix the puns pawns on dark squares now
that might not be relevant
after the bishops get traded let's play
age six
preparing the sacred and beloved g5
imagining some position where my king is
centralized this pawn is still supported
at some point I want to have puns on c5
and b5 Wow so we could be trading a lot
so I have a chance here to imbalance
things a bit more I could take with the
bishop and then like rook f7
could take with night - let's take with
bishop sometimes to outplay lower the
players you need to create announces now
it's knife vs. bishop not sure which
piece is more effective I mean my knight
is nicely placed the bishop even though
it's in the center it's kind of short on
squares I might play g5 soon and then
like rook d7
I'm sensing we're gonna have some
endgame time scramble coming shortly a
lot of g5m alerts the anticipation is
real g5 on its way even if white plays
h4 I might still play g5 h for sure why
not and if the H file opens it might
benefit me cuz I could quickly access it
with rook h7 okay so tension is being
left rook u7 there's this move now I
have g4 it's interesting you'll play
rook e7 it's very forcing calculating
Bishop f6 g4 King f2 takes takes then h5
and the bishop can't touch my pawns
let's not mess up the move order check
the king's glued to the rook and then
I'll trade rooks I can also play rook e6
rookie 6 is actually a bit interesting
it's why rocky 6
yeah just tickling the bishop I think
maybe with rookie six I'd get some extra
time because if White's the one who
takes I get time activating my king how
so many g5 emotes Oh cuz I actually
played g5 makes sense so I have my pawns
on light squares Bishop can't touch him
and the King can't break through the
King is restricted by both both these
pawns at some point I might want to
prepare f4 and then create like some
defended past cheap haunt c3 is logical
maybe time to take can trade everything
hmm
c3 is probably a good move
trying to calculate some endgame takes
takes King e6 the problem is politics
[Music]
if f4 in some position actually looks
really interesting
okay let's start with taking calculating
f4 in this position our Keaney six first
bikini six first
and then f4 oh this is I might be
sacking to pawns in the endgame this
looks very questionable but I it's it's
so nice like positionally okay there's
increments so I want flag I just
committed to pawns an endgame to just
damage light structure because I have
light square control one pawn fixes
these two pawns I can start with c6 I
think yeah so all these squares are in
my control so I can't really make
progress with the pawns and then I think
h4 d 4 will ultimately fall and this
pawn is a constant worry for white it
was a very interesting endgame Wow can I
just promote no I can't because f5 so
let's stop the pawn first the King can't
run too far this way because then I do
promote also I'm winning h4 and I'll
have two connected passers theirs might
just be winning for black let's take
I'll move back and my king will be
optimized hmm can do this in 12 seconds
should be enough time can just push and
this is very nice set up the night the
King the pawn restricts everything the
bishop it's an outpost bishop but it's
not so effective it doesn't stop the
pawns can do this just promote the king
is literally stuck even like oh wow I'm
just mating in two moves I can promote
to Bishop even and if pushed I just take
that's so funny it was just force mate
yeah the King has no escape here Wow
even if I if I didn't have a jeep on and
my pawn was like on each side and it's
still oh no I need the Jeep under
control f3 that was fun I was like a
positional endgame gambit maybe I'll put
that on youtube and call it positional
endgame gambit let's go back to pawns
yeah that first a deep on then I thought
it was all about like just the light
square control and this pawn is just
it's worth a lot more than a single pawn
so for the future people watching on
YouTube I hope you enjoyed that game be
sure to LIKE subscribe comment share the
video on reddit and I'll be back in the
future